[Music]
haiya today we're gonna talk about how
to build a custom sentiment analysis
model with Google Cloud Auto ml natural
language if you've played with the
natural language API before you might
have seen that it can tell you the
sentiment of a block of text like
whether a tweet is mostly positive or
mostly negative but what about for text
with domain-specific language for
example let's say we're trying to
classify the sentiment of a tweet like
Delta I was waiting on the tarmac for
two hours that's a made-up tweet by the
way sorry Delta an out of the box
sentiment model it would tell us this
tweet is neutral it doesn't realize that
being stuck on the runway is a bad thing
for this we'll use Auto ml natural
language to train a custom sentiment
model to do that we'll need a labelled
data set today we'll build a model that
identifies the sentiment of tweets about
Airlines using a data set built by
CrowdFlower to prepare our data set all
we have to do is save the tweet with
their labels in a csv the leftmost
column indicates what we should use a
given example for like testing training
or validation the label on the right are
the tweet sentiment scores which in our
dataset have been labeled by a human
being zero is very negative ones
intermediate and two is very positive
within the auto ml natural language tool
we'll choose to launch an auto ml
sentiment app next we'll import our data
by clicking add dataset here we want to
choose sentiment analysis we can upload
the data by importing it as a CSV
directly or as a zip file but I've
already uploaded my CSV to a Google
cloud storage bucket so I'm just going
to import it that way down here by
sentiment scale well tell Auto ml the
range of sentiment scores to expect in
the data set since our scores go from 0
the most negative to to the most
positive we'll select two is the maximum
sentiment score now the data is
importing this could take a few minutes
to finish once data is imported we'll
see it here in the text items tab we can
click into an example and make sure it
has the right sentiment score or change
it if it doesn't notice we also have the
counts of how many examples we have for
each label on the Left we'll need at
least a hundred examples per label to
start training we can begin training a
model by navigating over to the train
tab and click
start training training a model can take
up to three hours so hold tight you'll
get an email when it's done when
trainings finished we'll be able to see
our model here in the train tab we can
see how well it did by clicking see full
evaluation here in the evaluate panel we
can click in to see the performance of
our model the metrics we care about our
precision and recall up top we can see
both but if we click into a single
sentiment label we can see it broken
down for each category precision tells
us of the tweets that our model did
label zero how many really were zero
recall on the other hand tells us of all
the entire tweets in the data set or
percent of those that should have been
labeled zero dinner model actually end
up labeling zero another useful tool is
the confusion matrix it tells us how the
real labels of the data set compared to
the labels that our model predicted for
example ninety one point three percent
of the time the model accurately
predicted that tweets with the label
zero should have had label zero but
twenty six point seven percent of the
time it also thought that tweets with
label one those that are just neutral
should be labeled zero if we click on
one of these boxes we see examples of
what the model correctly and incorrectly
labeled in the predict tab we can start
actually using our model hosted by
Google we just have to think of some
positive and negative airline tweets to
type into this box and there we go
Auto ml natural language is custom
sentiment analysis feature and knows
that losing your luggage is not fun
that's all for now
have fun modeling
[Music]